all right today's question comes from
steve in kansas
steve asks my wife and i discuss our
budget every two weeks but it never goes
where it's supposed to go
she always finds something to spend
money on but when i want to buy
something she shuts me down
i also cashed out a mutual fund and it
had 70 thousand dollars in it to pay an
inheritance
from an inheritance to pay down our
mortgage but she's dragging her feet on
paying it off
more of a statement than a question yeah
you know whenever i hear this dave i
this is never about a budget for me
i always think this is about
um relational power right there's some
either she's self-soothing with this or
he's writing this in trying to you know
feeling like the hero a little bit but
this is the only play she's got in this
marriage only place she can be heard
or i guess somebody can just be a jerk
but whenever somebody says we talk about
this stuff a lot man you can talk
circles around things unless but if
you're not talking towards something
it's a waste of a conversation right
yeah the the illusion about
communication is is that it has actually
happened
right we said a lot of words and so we
parted ways
what i what i run into with this is uh
kind of the nerd or free spirit thing
i'll give you a guess i'm going to read
some mail here read between the lines
i'm going to guess and say steve
is the nerd he is a uh uh he's
a spreadsheet he's a detailed guy right
and
she is the free spirit and to steve
when you write it down and we all agree
to it in his mind
it was chiseled in stone by god and he
brought it back from mount sinai
right you know he's like god says this
it's in stone this is not only a
contract you will be struck by lightning
if you violate the contract right
a wee bit parasitical right a wee bit
uptight
right her on the other hand she's still
functioning at a freaking eight-year-old
level
and just did he bops into life and did
he bops out and looks at her husband's
thing says yeah babe let's do it and
then wanders off and doesn't anymore
make a contract
then fly to the moon and she little does
she know she just signed up
with a contract with big boy contract
but a budget is a
is a is it should be directional right
it should be a contract
right but it should not be an uptight
contract and what's the problem steve is
is she does not view it the way you view
it she doesn't think she's breaking her
word
and you think that she's a liar and it
becomes
right and it becomes about who's got the
strength here
yeah in his language i also cashed out
this mutual fund now i'm
i'm i'm taking what uh she's going to
take that power i'm going to take this
one and no
man you are the only thing that happens
here is you what you've got to do is you
have to raise the level of the
language to communicate and go okay
honey
when i say this it means to me
we are pinky swear spit shake we are you
know
cutting our little hand here putting a
little blood on there we're signing an
oath in blood
that this is by god what we're going to
do and i want to ask her
what is it and if you sign this if you
say yes i agree to this
that's to me what you are doing so when
you don't do these things honey it makes
me feel like you are lying
and she needs to go whoa i had no idea i
was signing up for that trip
and i then i want to ask her why are you
unwilling to unable to lock arms with
this guy
and stick to what you said you were
going to do because she's not even in
the same ballpark she just drove off did
whatever the crap she wanted to do
but look at this they're both they're
both violating but what a mouse is they
didn't have the same
language to say this is a contract and
they don't have the same destinations
where they're headed
yeah but well they both looked at it and
they both said yeah let's go to florida
but he meant he meant that in the
morning and she meant next year
or she meant it'll work out yeah we'll
get there eventually we'll get there
and it's just no where is the car packed
why aren't you in the car his response
well then i want to buy something yeah
well that's just hit back
that's just childish [ __ ] back yeah yeah
and uh
there's interesting you know in other
words if i'm this inheritance thing is
an emotional thing to him
and it should be that's a valid thing if
he says i'm going to take my mama's
money
and put it on the mortgage that's a big
deal to me so when i put this money in
the account
and by the way steve why didn't you just
write the freaking check why are you
waiting on her to do it
uh but anyway aside from that uh it's
straight into the mortgage
right you know it's like but she's
dragging her feet why is she dragging
her feet just
write the dadgum check you said you were
gonna do it or did we have a
conversation
about hey we got this inheritance let's
talk through what we're gonna do with it
we all agreed
yeah right did we have that conversation
did steve with his math
and his uh excel sheets create his old
universe here yep i
i i got to tell you the reason i know
this stuff is exactly the mistakes i
made
it's because i'm the spreadsheet guy i'm
the decisive guy
and to me by god when you say you're
gonna do something that's just like you
said you're gonna do it so why aren't
you doing it
i can't stand it we're the reverse in my
house and sharon's like well i didn't
really
mean i was like gonna you know sell one
of the kids i mean and now you got one
of the kids up for sale you know it's
like
well 70 000 like let's we're going to
play with five
and so 65 000 is great right well sort
of a minute but i didn't exactly mean it
you know and so we've had to go oh look
okay
we are completely agreeing on this date
this amount
this is the thing and you get a vote and
i get a vote
do you feel heard yes i feel heard
then by god you're gonna stick to your
word okay
i mean we've had to have these type of
real clear
words in our com visceral words in our
communication early on
to get where we're locked in because now
she i mean
to me once you say it's not if for nerds
if it's on the spreadsheet it's law
it's just that's law and for free
spirits like me it's an approximation
yeah let's get there yeah that's a good
general
concept i like that you have a
spreadsheet we're all going to be 50
someday right yeah we're gonna get there
yeah it's a it's what they're saying he
made a contract and she didn't sign it
it actually she signed it in his mind
but she didn't know it
that's my point that's what i'm saying
and i think that's a great
exercise for every married couple to say
we've got to be in agreement we've got
to be in unity
and you're going to use different
languages rachel's book know yourself
know your money he's got
tons of stuff in there about how your
spouse is viewing this
conversation about money and how you're
viewing the conversation about money and
it comes from all these different angles
know yourself know your money and it's
just it's so powerful
yeah and i as the free spirit there's
this
i always come back to this thing about
control
yeah this power this what do you mean i
can't i'm in this house and i'm in
and that's me being immature that's what
it comes down to no i mean
because the flow of money is about
control
but what you have to fight to do in this
communication is
uh relinquish half of the control
like sharon and i at this moment are in
this dispute over a large purchase
and we talked about it before i walked
out of the house this morning okay
because we have a rule when when we're
not both on the page
we don't do it until we both get there
we don't do it whether it's a large gift
on you know philanthropy we're giving
whether it's a major move down here at
the office with a bunch of money or
something like that or whether it's a
purchase and in this case it's a
purchase of something we're looking at
that we're but but she's like well i
think we just
you got the money what's wrong with you
you just need to do this and i'm like
nope not ready
this is not right it doesn't feel right
it's just not the same one so you both
have a veto card
you both can play the the trump card if
you've ever played you know hand of
cards where you can play a trump card
i'm
not talking about donald i'm talking
about the joker game okay i'm not
talking about the joker i'm talking
about a trump card
so but the the uh you know you've got
you both have a vote that can call it
and so
what we do is it forces us to do nothing
until we can find the thing that we both
can agree to where you align
and that means you have patience
intentionality and a tongue
we value the unity more than we value
the thing
how long did that take to get to ten
years
a minute ten years yeah after going
broke you know
first thing we did is try to kill each
other when we're going broke right like
we're talking about with that couple on
that debt free screen but
you know that this is vital stuff right
here y'all
because all the data points that we have
in our millionaire study that ramsay did
gives you very clear guidelines
that very few people become millionaires
uh
without spousal participation and
spousal unity you got to be alive and
spout
in spite of these communication
breakdowns you just don't do it you do
it
because you force these conversations at
a real healthy level
that's why dr john dolone is here
because he can talk about this stuff
intelligently this is the ramsay show